[Musique]
savez j
au casting qui s'est fait spontanément
naturellement ils sont tous venus avec
joie avec envie le tournage s'est passé
avec joie avec envie et là c'est là
c'est la cerise sur le gâteau part donc
à la cerise est aussi grosse que le
gâteau bonsoir à tous et à tout comme on
a coutume de le dire à cannes cérémonie
pluvieuse cérémonie heureuse
bonsoir ce soir au sommaire me souviens
des festivals du journal du festival le
titre de ton court métrage judith hôtels
d'accor et fantasmagorique fait que j'ai
fait donc clairement onirique un peu
dark donc là nous partez pour ça il sait
pas alors je vais essayer de bien
qu'émoussé plate landsman blackman avec
un jeu de mot black belle ac kaka cas
puisque ce nouveau film réalisé par
spike lee et l'histoire vraie d'un
policier américain qui a infiltré le
qustions histoire bien sûr
de venir troubler un tout petit peu les
opérations du caucus clan l'histoire
vraie donc de cet officier de police
exactement arrivé c'est un peu compliqué
l'américano
[Musique]
merrick africain et américain du rafale
vive la france les femmes dans ce film
dont moi fred forte en électron libre
c'est pas très forte en coûte le moment
où on commence le film tant mieux belle
histoire
alexandre avec un documentaire qui vous
est consacré cette année oui c'est un
peu étrange mais pourquoi étrange
est-ce que c'est pas très facile de se
regarder sur un écran au palais de soi
même et de son travail mais j'espère que
ça
vera des passions d'aidé
ma carrière peut-être compositeur qui
vont avoir envie de buzzer yahia le fils
qui s'appelle khairi chaud
bonjour bonjour merci de parler les
vidéos et la fille
sasaki mieux c'est bonjour ça se dit
bonjour formidable mais pas le jeu tu
vas glv.a c'est à ces âmes
assemat mal voilà on a notamment aperçu
naomi campbell ou encore beladina or y
en a quand même certaines qu'on voit
tous les soirs
est ce qu'elles vont voir du coup tous
les films pas vraiment en fait